habitant de saint laurent les signaler
donc à bruit suspect que c'est à dire
bruit de moteur coupures et un bruit
sourd après plus rien et donc il a
informé les services de secours qui sont
intervenus
on me dit qu'il ya plusieurs témoignages
et qui ont eu à peu près en même temps
dans des villages alentours donc avec
l'officier d'intervention justice on a
fait une première tournée de
reconnaissance en cherchant à trouver
des témoignages cohérente savoir si
vraiment c'était fondé on est descendu
sur la commune de gruss ou là on avait
plusieurs témoignages concordants
à partir de là donc ils ont ils ont
déclenché des véhicules supplémentaires
et ont organisé des tournées de
pendant deux visions pendant avant 18
heures juste avant la nuit puisque le
plafond était très bas donc on était en
visibilité de 200 mètres maximum à ce
moment qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant
actuellement quel est votre rôle c'est
le rôle des secours des gendarmes à
l'euro l'a donc là il s'enfonce dans
quête d' expertise donc j'ai mis à
disposition du pc et de pc à la salle
rue des chassaintes rochon et donc après
il faudrait également qu'on trouve un
local pour centraliser toutes les tous
les débris de quillan j'imagine que
depuis hier pouvoir était pas quoi on
était mobilisée donc depuis 17h
ensuite on engager en coordination avec
mon adjoint jean paul gaultier le maire
délégué de saint laurent et on engager
tous les élus disponibles de la commune
dont monsieur billets pour d'autres
d'autres élus de saint orens pour guider
guy des services de secours dans les
chemins tous les chemins de la commune
de nuit donc seulement accessible c'est
ça difficilement accessibles donc
principalement quelques katas bien
entendu ils ont d'oise est donc très
très difficiles et les conditions de
pluie de la nuit précédente